[Music]
hello dear friends once again thank you
for joining us in the program I'd like
to know it is a pleasure and a privilege
for us to come to you with this program
to answer the questions that you so de
sent to us we want to remind you that
you can send your questions or your
inquiries to the following email address
which is TV at Sam tv.org we do our best
to answer them as quickly as possible
some of you have actually uh sent an
email saying when we get our answer in
in the program and we apologize for the
delay sometimes just getting to your
question takes some time as we try to do
a thorough uh understanding and research
in the questions that we have so with
that said I would like to once again
introduce Pastor Stan bour with me what
a blessing to have you Pastor bour and
thank you for allowing us to start this
program with a word of prayer so I want
to ask you to you know send us to the
throne of Heaven by praying to the Lord
let's pray Father in Heaven never should
we open your holy book without prayer
amen because the spirit that actually
inspired the writers is the only one who
can come and explain his book to to us
yes so we ask for divine
wisdom as we open the pages of this holy
book amen help us to answer the
questions
correctly and I ask that you will bless
those who are watching the program that
they might be blessed as well we thank
you for the privilege of prayer we know
that in eternity past you already
answered this qu this uh prayer because
you knew that we were going to ask in
the name of Jesus amen amen
amen okay pastor we have these questions
wonderful questions today and one comes
to us from yarel Aon Figaroa and the
question is the
following just a curiosity of mine did
Jesus ever get sick and that's
interesting question and uh you know be
I think that it's a question that
perhaps young people and and and even
you know main adults have maybe asked or
have Wonder but not really ask the
question so I'm thankful that gel is
taking the courage to ask this question
it's a good you know question to have
especially as we know that in those days
in those times many people were sick as
a matter of fact we know from just going
through the study of the scriptures
through the gospels that Christ spent
more time
healing than preaching or teaching so
people were sick in those days they
didn't have clinics they didn't have a
doctor so you know getting sick was
something you know very common as it is
today even but did Christ get sick what
can we say about that from the word of
God well first of all I can be certain
that uh Joseph and Mary knowing that
this was a special child because of of
the Annunciation yes uh that they would
have taken the greatest care to make
sure that Jesus followed uh healthy
habits physical habits mhm um I'm sure
that he lived in harmony with with the
principles of Health yeah uh no doubt
about it because uh the Bible tells us
that uh in Hebrews chapter 4 that he was
tempted in all things like us except
that he didn't sin in other words Jesus
did not indulge uh in in the practice of
intemperance things that would harm his
body uh but as far as he ever got sick
or not I don't I haven't found anything
that says whether he did or not but my
hunch based on uh the fact that he was
the son of God and he was perfect uh and
he lived in in harmony with the
principles of temperance that probably
he didn't get sick I don't know if you
agree no absolutely Pastor B I mean as a
matter of fact you were mentioning you
know his parents um they had you know
the Lord had given the Jewish Nation
laws that would prevent them from
sickness he actually said to them you
know back in in in the Deuteronomy we
have that part where he tells them that
if you follow my laws and my
Commandments none of the diseases that
came upon the Egyptians will come upon
you and this is the LA the laws that the
lord gave them these are not just only
the Ten Commandments but also their
health and and you know civil laws the
parents of Jesus knew these laws and
notice that in you know Luke Chapter 2
vers uh 39 and
40 when the family returns to Nazareth
she says so when they had performed all
things according to the law of the Lord
they returned to Galilee to their own
City Nazareth notice how it says so
important that the parents it was a baby
the child still you know they perform
all things according to the law of the
Lord and then he says verse 40 and the
child grew and became strong in spirit
filled with wisdom and the grace of God
was upon him so it tells us that Jesus
was a healthy child and we have to I
guess the question that you know you
brought up is you know how do why do we
get sick most of the time there may be
exceptions to this you know but most of
the time we break one of the laws of
Health the Bible tells us that our
bodies are temples of the Holy Spirit I
we to keep it you know not to fill with
impure things so Jesus fully understood
the need to have a healthy body so he
was he would not sin as you will mention
in Hebrews it says that he was without
sin so he never sinned he never
committed transgression of the law and
that's is including laws that affect our
bodies so Christ never
transgress the law so he never sin
therefore he never received sickness
from transgression of the law now you
may some might say well what about you
know uh when he became very weak you
know or he almost fainted in his
struggles one of the examples is when he
went was taken by the spirit to the
desert after he was baptized to be
tempted and he fasted for 40 days and he
was weak and he was hunger and spirit
prophecy mentions that he even you know
was so weak that he could not you know
clearly discern I mean his his eyes you
know he was just physically weak imagine
40 days without eating so that is not
sickness let me make it that clear that
is not being sick he was just we because
he was trying to prepare himself for
that mission he had then if as we also
know in the struggle he had in getsemane
when he was arguing or or pleading with
the Lord saying Lord take away the cup
from me he was so afflicted by the by
this struggle by this you know fight I
guess with his own will and following
the will of God saying you know his
temptation was to give up this this step
of separation from God
and just say I'm giving up or saying
Lord not my will but your will let me go
through this process so in that
experience he was bleeding you know he's
he was bleeding uh sweating blood as it
mentions the Bible and he became so weak
that even an angel had to help come and
support him so we see these things where
he was weak he maybe almost fainted but
that's not sickness that is just an
experience of extreme anguish in
pleading and and preparing for for for
the last part of his life so uh did
Christ ever get sick I don't see that
from the scriptures at all uh and by I
mean by that you know because he never
transgressed the law so uh and I don't
think necessarily the Lord allowed an
Affliction to come like he come to came
to job uh we don't see that in the Bible
as well so I don't see that Jesus was
ever sick yeah what what we need to say
is that we don't have any special light
yeah on whether he got sick or he didn't
get sick um you know I know people these
days who have a very strong immune
system because they follow the laws of
health and very occasionally they might
get sick but I don't see that happening
to Jesus yeah yeah amen okay well the
next question comes to us uh from Addis
and this is from New York City so he's
saying the following he has actually two
questions he says hello I'm Maris from
New York and I have two questions
Preamble for the first question I think
I know an answer because it is just
requires a mindset change if you don't
view the unborn child as human and then
of course you would want to kill it but
if you think of it in the way God does
the then does then the answer should be
clear so pray first and follow councils
and the principles in the Bible but
maybe I'm missing something so this is
the the question he has how do you argue
against abortions that were done on
because of extreme circumstances like
the mother's life being threatened
incest rape and the common arguments so
that's the first question he has in
regards to abortion for those who have
had that procedure and these
circumstances or for those who support
under the circumstances what can we say
about that particular question he has
even though he answers someone himself
he's saying maybe it's just a mindset
change but what can we say about that
Pastor
well it's a difficult question and
there's different views on on this um
God is The Giver of Life
right um and and therefore man does not
have the right to take a life and that
would include the life of The Unborn
right um you know people say well what
about if the mother's life is being
threatened mhm what about
incest what about
rape you know what about
uh all these things yeah well the fact
is that God doesn't say well you know
you need to respect life but they have
all this long list of uh of exceptions
to the rule there's a case in the Bible
where the mother died died mhm uh that's
the case of Rachel right she died when
uh when benoni Benjamin was born right
uh that's in Genesis
31:18 she gave her
life for him to be born yeah so so if
the mother's life is in danger the
question is cannot God uh prevent the
danger I mean can't the woman still have
the child and God preserve her life if
it's will of course he can um you know
I've known uh women who have uh have
been the victims of of
incest and you know the everything turns
out well they decide to have the baby
everything turns out well if I could
just share an
anecdote and this is a true story I
pastored in West Frankfurt
Illinois and uh that's the that's the
church where 3 ABN is well they're in
Thompsonville but but at that time
that's where the Shelton lived and there
was a a boy his name was Jeffrey and I'm
sure many people know this story so I'm
not sharing anything that's new and they
had uh uh Jeffrey had Down syndrome a
real bad case of down
syndrome and you know up to that point I
um I kind of had a negative view of uh
you know you call they're called
mongoloids which is not the really the
way a very nice way of expressing it um
and uh I learned a lot about having a
child that is not
normal uh every time that I went to the
house of uh the the Shelton yeah and
Jeffrey was there I went many
times he was always waiting for me when
he knew that I was coming he was always
waiting for me in a tree that was in the
front yard M and when he saw that my car
was driving in he would start
clapping then I would go in I visit the
family and I would sit in the living
room and Jeffrey would come and sit on
my
lap and he would pet my face you know
and sometimes when I was preaching in
church he would stand up and he would
start preaching along with
me he he had feelings and emotions of
course of course he had love yeah that
kid loved me mhm uh and and so you know
say well you know uh if it's incest you
might have a child that's not normal in
quotation
marks we can learn a
lot uh from from a child that is born
that is not in our definition normal
right so do we have a right to take a
life because of extenda circumstances or
should we
leave the decision in the hands of God
that's uh a question that each person
has to answer but I believe in the
sanctity of life I believe that uh we
need to leave things into the hands of
God absolutely and not take things into
our own hands amen I I think that's uh
that's the right approach to to this
question pastor and I 100% agree with
you in how we're to approach this
particularly difficult question and and
one that we need to be firm about H from
like you said the Lord is the one that
can make the decision if it's his will
but if his will is for such a situation
to continue I think we need to not
partake or take that authority to take
the life of anyone even in unborn child
yeah before you know it's time um so
continue with the next question he has
the friend from from New York the
question he has the second question is
when demons start or when demons start
pretending to be the dead loved ones or
beings from the other worlds what should
I do so when demons start doing this
what should he do and I think he says I
be scared to watch videos involving them
and for me and my non-adventist family
so I guess he's concerned that there's
going to be a moment where you're gonna
see demons approaching like dead ones
and maybe appearing as aliens or as
people from other worlds or something
like that you know when they appear what
should he
do the Bible says resist the devil and
he will flee from you yeah you know they
need to be rebuked in the name of Jesus
exactly Satan fears the name of Jesus
because Jesus is far more powerful than
he is uh but unfortunately in recent
years movies that emphasize the occult
yeah have
proliferated you know like the leaves of
autumn yeah we should not expose our
minds to those movies yeah because we're
being conditioned yes and and Ellen
White in early writings says that the
counterfeit that Satan is going to do of
supposed dead relatives who appear to us
is going to be so real she says the
counterfeit is perfect
mhm and she says that we are supposed to
be prepared to to say to the devil to
those those
demons the Dead the living know that
they will die but the dead know nothing
depart from me in the name of the Lord
you know we say oh you know if I if I
have a dead relative of me I'll
immediately no know it's the devil the
devil's very cunning yeah we can't have
confidence in that right uh you know
when when Satan showed Jesus all the
kingdoms of the world Ellen White says
that he refused to look he turns away
yeah uh because the Satan did not show
uh Jesus all the bad things in the world
all the homeless in the streets right no
he showed them all the glory of the
kingdoms and Jesus refused to look yeah
and so we need not to expose our minds
Amen to things that will condition us uh
to to accept uh uh you know spirits of
devils U appearing to us amen I think
that's a very you know good answer
pastor and one that we need to keep heed
you know we when we are approached by
any of these things and people G are
going to go through especially when we
lose a loved one some people you know
it's hard for them to to receive
consolation and we have to also be
careful with our own feelings we Foster
feelings of of longing of of like
missing the individual and not trusting
the word of God that you know if they
die in Christ we will see them again if
we don't you know strengthen our our
mind our emotions and we let our
feelings Satan is going to tap on those
feelings and he might present and he
will appear to you as your Lov mother or
whatever might be and I've know of cases
who people who have knowing the truth
have embraced that deception and you're
thinking how is that possible well maybe
you're as you said either you're
accustoming your mind to the idea of the
immortality of the soul in some way or
also you are fasing those feelings or or
those emotions strong affection to
someone who is resting until the Lord's
come so we have to be very careful with
that and and white clearly states that
Satan will appeal to the emotional side
absolutely you know imagine a mother
looks just like mother smells like her
sounds like her she says the voice the
voice is perfect just like the mother
and oh son you know it's me you know and
appealing to the emotions if you base
everything on your emotions you're going
to be deceived it's kind of like when
Satan personates the second coming of
Christa oh I I you know I I know that
it's going to be the devil because
because he's going to be walking on the
earth and and you know we know that
Jesus isn't going to touch the Earth and
we say that theoretically yeah but you
read the description that Ellen White
gives of Satan's personation of Christ
you know he's of dazzling brightness he
says some of the beautiful things that
Jesus said uh you know the the
multitudes exert uh PE pressure they say
oh yes this is Christ and and you know
everything is is appearing like it's
like it's Christ yeah but God's people
must be prepared to answer with the
scriptures and that's the key Pastor
word you know as you mentioned we have
to know that we trust the word of God
not our eyes not our feelings not our
senses because that's how the enemy is
going to deceive and he's going to
deceive many through this you know
sensorial things sensorial ways and and
like you said if if we don't truly put
our trust in God's word and are learning
to even now in our own experience in our
own Temptations to say you know that
said the Lord so that you can reject and
resist the devil and he can flee from
you if you don't start to doing that you
will be deceived in the last days and
and maybe many are going to follow that
that delusion that deception that the
enemy will do all right we have uh maybe
for one more question and that's a good
question that comes to us from Dolores
and the question is this who will the
righteous be reigning over during the
1,000 years because it says in the Bible
that they will reign with Christ for a
thousand years so who are they reigning
over what's you know what people what
kingdom are they reigning over is that
what is is meaning in this verse well
basically uh there there reigning with
Christ it's Christ that's reigning yes
but but they're going to sit with him on
his throne right so you could you might
be able to say that they're co- Regents
with Christ um you know the fact is that
uh Satan and his angels are going to be
over in this world during that time
maybe they're going to be reigning over
over him the Satan persecuted them he
mistreated them he tried to deceive them
yes and now instead of being the person
cuted now they're reigning yes and and I
think that you know as the Pastor Paul
mentions that in regards to the the
aspect reigning is also an experience of
judging you know the the concept of
reigning means also judging and
particularly during Thousand Years the
Apostle Paul tells us that uh you know
don't you know that you're going to you
know judge the world and and the angels
and so there's going to be this period
of a thousand years that we will
actually be like with Christ sitting in
the throne but part of the reigning
means judgment going through the
Judgment of the wicked Judgment of those
who are lost judging going through the
Judgment of of you know even Satan and
the angels that de deceive the world so
these are the parts of the reigning that
we are going to be actively involved
we're going to go through the we're
going to review the Judgment of God that
he made for the safe for the for the
save and for the lost and so this is
what reining means there's a there's a
part of judging that God is reserving
for the Saints to do with Jesus during
the Thousand Years so I think that's
also important because we're going to
determine the outcome each sentence as
well I mean you know the Lord is
GNA give us the ability to to with him
you know put the sentence to each one so
that's part of reigning also means I
think that's important to keep in mind
yeah and the throne that Jesus sits on
during the Millennium is a throne of
judgment right and we know that God's
people will participate in that judgment
because in 1 Corinthians chapter 6: 1
to3 the Apostle Paul says don't you know
that we're going to judge U Angels
Angels Satan and his angels yeah uh
don't you know that we're going to judge
the world which means worldings so in a
certain sense God's people by performing
a work of judgment are before
the wicked actually resurrect they're
reigning over them in the sense that
they're performing a work of judgment
absolutely so this is a thousand years
of the the righteous individuals the
righteous uh with Christ obviously are
working through this judgment period for
those who are lost and especially for
Satan and his angels who will receive a
sentence according to their deeds to
their works and this is why also we will
you know the Lord will open every little
thing every secret thing as as the Bible
mentions you know before the before the
the the redeemed we will know why one
particular individual is not there why
those who we thought would be in heaven
are not there and you know and and find
out the reasons about their experience
so that's part the reason why there's a
thousand years of reigning amen well
thank you once again uh dear friends for
allowing us to come to you our program
is always possible thanks to your
contributions to your donations to those
who are supporting the ministry and we
really thank you for your support as it
helps us to continue to work in these
programs and many many more like that
and we also thank you for your prayers
are so important to us so please
continue uh to keep our ministry in your
prayers and we thank you once again for
all your emails and all your uh
questions that you send to this program
may God bless you and looking forward to
seeing you next time here in I like to
know
[Music]